turning out to the war in Ukraine Russia
has renewed deadly missile strikes just
days after ending a military Rebellion
at least 10 people including children
were killed when a missile hit a busy
restaurant in eastern Ukraine yesterday
evening dozens of people were hurt Ian
Lee is in Ukraine with more on the
attack
Twisted Metal and concrete is All That
Remains of this popular pizza restaurant
last evening two Russian missiles hit
while the place was packed with the
dinner rush
people frantically helped the injured
while looking for loved ones and friends
the city sits about 20 miles from the
front and has come into the crosshairs
before many of the victims of Russia's
missile attacks are civilians some not
even old enough to understand what's
happening
everything has been blown up this
witness says I see destruction
everywhere it's fear or
for hours Rescuers pulled survivors from
the rubble the strike signals it's
business as usual for Russia after last
weekend's mutiny
[Music]
the Kremlin tried to project power and
control at a military ceremony in Moscow
yesterday
President Vladimir Putin thanked Russian
troops for preventing a civil war
The Man Behind the Rebellion Evgeni
pagosian last seen leaving the Russian
city of rostov arrived in Belarus
yesterday as part of the deal that ended
the crisis
but the country's president who brokered
the deal hinted that from safety may not
be guaranteed saying he had urged
President Putin not to kill him
here in cave Ukrainian officials watched
the Mutiny closely with one advisor to
the president saying that countdown has
begun to the end of Putin Tony
Ian Lee Forest once again in Ukraine Ian
thank you very much